we're going to talk about Nicholas
sturgeon turning into a transphobic
bigger yeah she refuses to put this
eilogram into a women's prison where she
belongs with her penis yes exactly she's
got a penis and it belongs in a women's
prison exactly why Nicola sturgeon is
refusing her right and an opportunity to
be there and do her thing do what she's
best at exactly sexually assaulting
women yes other women I should say right
because trans women are women but for
some reason for instance they've decided
not to put her her in a women's prison
which I think is bigger Trinity it is it
shows phobic if trans women are women
and that is the blankets it's a fact
it's a biological fact a biological fact
I mean it's not because we've all done
GCSE biology but shut your mouth
trans women and women well said strong
argument exactly which is basically what
what the argument is it is shut your
mouth trans women or women correct